it's tremendously disappointing that the
government sort of secretly did all the
stuff and didn't tell us I don't think
we can have a democracy if you know
we're having to protect you and our
users from the government's for stuff
that would never had a conversation
about them right and I don't mean we
have to know what the particular
terrorist acts they're worrying about
protecting us from but we do need to
know what the parameters of it is what
kind of surveillance the government's
gonna do and how and why and I think we
haven't had that conversation I've been
amazed the more I learn about technology
the more I realize I don't know and
that's because its technological horizon
the thing that you can see to do next
the more you learn about technology the
more you learn what's possible a lot of
what we try to do recently is just make
your devices work make them understand
your context Google now you know knows
where you are knows what may unite might
need and just getting not all to work on
you know there's a billion Android
devices now we just recently did
chromecast so we're just starting to
work on televisions we just announced
Android wear this week for wearables so
really having computing work and
understand you you understand that
information we really haven't done that
yet now I'm really dismayed most people
think companies are basically evil do
they get a bad rap and I think that's
somewhat correct so I mean companies are
doing the same incremental thing that
they did 50 years ago or 20 years ago
that's not really what we need we need
especially in technology we need
revolutionary change not incremental
change you once said actually I think
I've got this about right that that you
might consider rather than giving your
money if you leaving it to some cause
just simply giving it to Elon Musk
because you had confidence that he would
change the future well if you want
therefore yeah if you want to go to the
Mars ounce to go to Mars to back up
humanity that's the where they go but
it's a company and it's a philanthropic
home so I think you know we aim to do is
kind of similar things that I think you
asked we have a lot of employees at
Google who have become pretty wealthy
you know they were you know people make
a lot of money in technologies while the
people in the room are pretty wealthy
you're working because you want to
change the world you want to make it
better and why isn't the company they
work for
were they not just of your time but your
money as well I mean but we don't have a
concept of that that's now how we think
about companies and I think it's sad
because companies are most of our effort
now they're where most of people's time
is where a lot of the money is because I
think like for us to help out more than
we are